En un pasado vídeo os hablamos de cómo Teodoro Obiang y su familia había
secuestrado Guinea Ecuatorial, explotado propiolos recursos del país a beneficio
propio y acumula una fortuna milmillonaria:
"Yo diría que en este
país no hay pobreza.... habría lo que yo
califico como penuria"
Con todo ello, han condenado al pueblo guineano, el pueblo más rico de África a malvivir en
unas condiciones de extrema pobreza. En
este vídeo queremos profundizar un
poco más en el tema y analizar cómo
funciona el régimen de terror que bajo
una cínica apariencia democrática ha
consolidando el poder casi absoluto de la familia Obiang.
"Yo presumo de que soy un dictador porque él sinónimo de dictador viene de dictar normas".
Y es que hablar del gobierno de Guinea Ecuatorial
supone hablar de un entramado de corrupción camuflada como
un estado, que utiliza la represión y la
conducta criminal para lograr sus
objetivos.
Así lo indican no son los informes de
ONGs y la información procedente de la
oposición política sino que la propia
secretaria de estado de EEUU ha
publicado un duro informe en el que denuncia la total ausencia de respeto a los Derechos Humanos (DDHH)
que profesa el señor Obiang.
"Yo he visto cómo maltratan a personas
como si fueran animales, atarlos y
colgarlo de los postes cómo cerdos,
romperles las manos las piernas o los
pies reventarselos a base de golpes".
Pero ¿Cómo ha consolidado su poder Teodoro Obiang? ¿Cómo ha
convertido a guinea ecuatorial en una
especie de cárcel colectiva? pues
fundamentalmente aplicando una estrategia de  terror que podemos clasificar en
tres campos principales: la libertad de
expresión, asociación y reunión están
muy restringidas. Ejercer la oposición
activa o participar en política puede
tener consecuencias nefastas.
de hecho el pasado 24 de abril se
celebró...  cómo denominarlo... una farsa
electoral en la que teodoro obiang
obtuvo más del 93% de los votos.
"Nosotros tenemos la aceptación del
pueblo de Guinea Ecuatorial"
Los comicios estuvieron marcados por
toda una larga lista de irregularidades
por ejemplo el censo contenía escritos
a menores de edad y no residentes por
supuesto la oposición no tuvo acceso al
mismo y no es extraño porque todos los
miembros de la junta electoral son
nombrados por Obiang y eran  miembros de su partido.
Incluso la propia junta era
presidida por Clemente Ngonga, ministro
del interior además de todo esto la principal  candidatura de la oposición fue suspendida.
"Se han sumado a nuestra lucha
por la democracia por la libertad por
los derechos humanos y tienen miedo
igual que yo"
Durante la celebración de esas mismas
elecciones se cerrarán organizaciones
como el Centro de Estudios e Iniciativas
para el Desarrollo una de las pocas
asociaciones civiles independientes.
Por si esto no fuera suficiente, dos
días antes de las elecciones, unidades
del ejército y la policía de Malabo
rodearon la sede del partidos ciudadanos
por la innovación y retuvieran en su
interior a más de doscientas personas
muchas de las cuales fueron finalmente
arrestadas y golpeadas: "Al menos tres heridos en
un ataque del ejército de Guinea
ecuatorial a la sede opositora"
No resulta extraño entender como Obing pudo hacerse con la práctica totalidad de
los votos, al final cualquier persona que
muestre desafección o critica
con este supuesto gobierno democrático se expone duras a consecuencias como perder
su trabajo ser perseguidos por la
policía o incluso ser encarcelados.
Pero esto le puede pasar hasta a los amigos del régimen es el caso de Roberto Berardi
que se atrevió a preguntarle a su socio
teodorín si había utilizado la
sociedad que tienen en común para
blanquear capitales en EEUU.
Esa pregunta acabó con su libertad y
hoy Roberto Berardi  se encuentra en
la prisión de Black Beach, una de las
prisiones más duras del mundo.
"No hay ni una una tortura... prácticamente "
Reporteros Sin Fronteras sitúa a Guinea Ecuatorialen su índice de libertad de prensa en el puesto 167 de 180, por su parte el
Comité de Protección de Periodistas
considera este país uno de los 15 con mayor
censura en todo el mundo. Omito decir que la coacción, el acoso, la violencia contra
los periodistas son más que comunes. Incluso en enero de 2014,
el gobierno llegó a detener a dos
periodistas extranjeros del Financial Times
que ellos mismos habían invitado para cubrir una conferencia de inversión.
El 20 de enero en Malabo, la capital de
Guinea Ecuatorial, agentes de seguridad
armados arrestaron a Javier Blas
redactor sobre África para el Financial Times
y Peter Chapman redactor senior
del mismo periódico, fueron detenidos y
sus equipos incautados por el tremendo
delito de conversar con miembros de
partidos políticos opositores".
Por si fuese poco las comunicaciones
privadas son monitoreadas y el acceso a
internet censurado, muchas webs
incómodas para el gobierno son bloqueadas,
y su tráfico es redirigido al portal
oficial de prensa del gobierno.
Así es como obiang ha conseguido
perpetuarse en el poder durante más de
30 años y los políticos españoles ¿Qué
dicen de todo esto?
Bueno pues la verdad es que Obiang ha
tenido buena relación con
prácticamente todos los presidentes en
españa salvo con Aznar que era notoriamente mala y con Suarez que no acabó del todo bien
"Cuando aparecen intereses económicos claros como los derivados de la exportación del
petróleo en guinea ecuatorial dejan de
interesarse por la falta de democracia
por las violaciones de derechos humanos"
Mariano Rajoy ha sido quien vergonzosamente ha visitado de nuevo a
Obiang desde que Felipe González lo
hiciera en 1991.
Sin embargo, aunque Mariano ha
intentado acercarse, el círculo de
amigos de Obiang en España, podríamos decir que se encuentra entre las
filas socialistas: el expresidente
Zapatero, Moratinos y José Bono han
realizado visitas privadas durante los
últimos años para reunirse con el dictador.
La última visita de Bono, de hecho, ha
sido escasamente a finales del mes de mayo de 2016,
a unas escasas semanas de celebrarse en las próximas elecciones en España.
"Bono se reune en Guinea con el hijo de Obiang que, a su vez, se ha querellado contra el diario Rombe"
para los que no conozcais la política española,
José Bono es como nuestra Hillary Clinton lo ha sido todo: presidente de Castilla la Mancha,
Diputado histórico en el Congreso, Ministro de Defensa y
Presidente del Congreso de los Diputados. ¿Es razonable que alguien como José Bono
vaya a reunirse con dictadores para
hacer negocios o lo que quiera que vaya  a hacer?
Por supuesto que está en su derecho de
hacer lo que le dé la gana pero esto
en otro país habría ocupado portadas
y habría sido una vergüenza nacional.
Pero ya sabéis: "Spain is different".
Si bien es cierto, tenemos a nuevos políticos que no tienen ningún temor en denunciar la
triste realidad de Guinea como por
ejemplo la diputada de origen
ecuatoguineano Rita Bosaho, de Podemos o Fernando Maura de Ciudadanos.
Vosotros qué pensáis ¿conseguirá Guinea
librarse de la lacra de los Obiang  y
ver el desarrollo y la libertad? ¿Podemos
hacer algo para contribuir a que se produzca?
Yo creo que sí, cuanta más gente
conozca qué pasa realmente allí menos
tolerantes seremos con la actitud de
presidentes como Rajoy que van a rendir
respeto a dictadores como Obiang en nombre de todos los españoles.
Esperamos tus comentarios ¡¡Un saludo y
hasta el próximo vídeo!!!!